[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host george
campbell ramsey personality host of the
entree leadership and fine print podcast
on the ramsey network is my co-host
today we help people build wealth do
work that they love and create real high
quality relationships we're thankful
you're here america thanks for being
with us open phones here as we talk
about your life and your money triple
eight eight two five five
two two five rachel's in miami to start
this hour off hi rachel how are you
hi dave i'm doing all right thank you
very much how are you guys doing better
than we deserve what's up in your
world uh well i'm going through a bit of
a hard time where i'm
stepping into a role of a caregiver for
my parents that has alzheimer's
and
yeah we've been working through the
steps up until then thankfully we got
our cars paid off
and any other out the way but we still
have
40 000 in student loans that we've been
making aggressive payments towards
and
um just with the alzheimer's situation
there's going to be about 8 000 between
medical and legal bills coming up so we
want to know whether we should put a
pause and
just aggressively save for that you
might go into i guess emergency mode
or how should we kind of address that
like try to gradually save up for that
but
yeah so um
who's got alzheimer's
uh my mother i'm sorry where's your dad
yeah
um he he's not involved because in this
she's she kind of
she doesn't want him around ever since
she has alzheimer's
yes she doesn't get a vote
yet
where's your dad
yeah he um
like he's also very emotionally unstable
so he never makes the situation better
and
um so they're still together but their
their relationship is bad
they're legally together but they're not
living together they don't live together
correct oh okay
do either one of them have any money
no unfortunately they've made a series
of bad decisions which led me to
being aggressive with with taking
control of my and my husband's finances
and getting things in order
both of us getting on the same page with
with your plan
wow kiddo i'm sorry yeah how old is your
mom
she's
65.
yeah so this is uh
pretty advanced
yeah yeah have you had
so what is the legal and medical bills
that you are responsible for
um so we're moving into guardianship
because she didn't even have anything
legally in place for power of attorney
and
and throughout the years it wasn't so
clear what it was what was causing it
now is when we're really getting a good
and now she's no longer capable of
granting that so you're having to ask
the court to give it to you
yep yeah right and
overall aside from that um
she is okay in that she has some savings
but we can't we obviously can't access
that to pay off the bills and we just
we're
how much comparison
how much savings she has about 15 000 in
savings well you need to access that
simultaneously with getting the
guardianship yeah
and if you're appointed conservator and
power of attorney you access that money
instantaneously
yeah they said that once that that comes
through it will be will be able to be
reimbursed for the legal fees
but before then we obviously we don't
want to put any legal fees on credit
cards we want to be able to have the
cash to go paying it in the moment um so
right now up front
stop a second okay
what i just said was
when you are given the guardianship and
you're given the power of attorney by
the courts
that should be you shouldn't have major
legal fees to you in advance of that
happening
yeah you got an attorney asking you for
eight thousand dollars up front to go
get this work done
well it's not exactly they just stated
that it would be an estimate of that
amount
after after they get it through but i
mean they can bill you and you pay them
after this court case
yeah
so you can use your mom to pay the mom's
money to pay her attorney it's her
attorney by the way
yeah
it's her bill so
ask them to
pretty much bill it and then it's paid
after the case is going i mean you may
have to put up a couple grand or
something up front as a retainer
but but putting up eight thousand
dollars up front to get a
conservatorship or a guardianship pass
through is kind of asinine that that you
need a new lawyer
well you're right on that they've only
was it what they've asked for is 3 000
as a retainer at the moment okay that's
not unreasonable okay okay so what is
your household income
um right now we are at a hundred
thousand a year okay and if you stop
taking care
you're gonna have to stop working to
take care of her is that the idea yeah
that's and once we do that we'll be at
sixty thousand
okay
all right
um
[Music]
can you guys pay the bills on sixty
thousand
yeah we can um we have we purchased a
townhome beforehand so we we only have
about um
it's about 16 000 mortgage with
insurance and taxes
so it's it's reasonable and we did it
prior to prior to me working we were
able to pay it just fine
and then what does long-term care look
like for her
financially and physically
that's that's kind of the concern
well
financially the care for her should be
covered because she does have good
medical insurance and it's covered a lot
of the
it's covered a lot
beforehand i think it's
it's going to be more so
probably more of an expense as far as
like food that we'll be providing for
her now and
there's no there's no long-term care
insurance you don't have nursing home
insurance
nursing we no she doesn't have that
but just the medical bills
yeah you got those cuts she's got those
covered yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay
well here's the thing
um there's no good this is a horrible
situation it's a tragedy
it's a mess
and you're a sweet person for taking
this on and loving your mother well all
right
but there's hard choices are going to be
made okay hard choice number one you've
already resigned yourself to and that is
you're going to lower your household
income and at a minimum lower slow your
personal financial progress in order to
take care of your mom
yeah that's what you're telling me right
yeah that's great yeah what i'm going to
add to the conversation
while i know your heart is breaking and
i love you and i want you to win
is there's also a reality at the end of
the story that may be her in a nursing
home and you're back to work
it might not be the end of the story is
her passing at your house
she may pass in a nursing home
because you may reach the point that
your family
is going to require your income again
let me give you an example okay if this
goes on two or three years it's not a
big deal you can probably make that it's
not going to set you back for decades
this goes on 15 years you can't do this
yeah
it's not going it's not it's not
sustainable for you emotionally for your
family
it's not sustainable for you financially
you're going to end up getting her some
nursing home care on medicaid
because she's broke and she qualifies
for medicaid
and so but on the short term yeah bring
her home and quit work for a little
while and let's see how this goes
and then if that slows down you're dead
snowball it just does i'm so sorry now
so tough
always have a healthcare power of
attorney always have long-term care
insurance
these two things would have solved a
whole lot right here
[Music]
chaos that's what it can feel like when
your business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year
netsuite gives you the visibility and
control of the things you need to grow
like your financials inventory hr
planning budgeting and more all in one
dashboard go to netsuite.com ramsey
right now to get their free white paper
jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
so
[Music]
well it's officially event week las
vegas i hope you're ready we're on our
way baby we're doing building wealth
this coming thursday night a live event
there are still some tickets available
the george campbell the rachel cruz and
dave ramsey will be doing the event
along with the dr john dolone and the
ken coleman and they'll be signing books
and taking pictures i will be doing some
of that as well and i will be doing a
couple of hour live event there in las
vegas about the true
aspects of building wealth the proven
process of financial principles
that work and we'll discuss some of the
um
shall we call them modern distractions
oh i like that i was going to say
schemes traps trends but i like modern
distractions too yeah things that would
distract you from doing smart things
there is an endless amount of those
there's only a few simple ways to
actually build wealth they're called get
rich quick
easy
and you know one of these things one of
the things that i'll talk about this
thursday night that i just love
that these all share in common
the person who's espousing them
always has
an air
of
condescension
that if you do not believe in their get
rich quick scheme
then you're just one of the little
people
or you're just in my case i'm a boomer
i'm too old to actually understand how
bitcoin works
i my intellect cannot grasp it because
of my age my advanced years
yeah that's a nice way to put it yeah
it's just it's it's humorous
uh that when you're 24 you can have that
much arrogance oh wait a minute i did
[Laughter]
so well there you go yeah and uh that's
exactly how i went broke i i and i would
have argued with you until the cows come
home as my grandmother would say
uh and how right i was and how wrong i
turned out to be
so i wanna get rich quick nothing down
real estate scheme scam whatever you
want to call it and it's still around to
this day a lot of people saying
leveraging debt is the way to build
wealth yeah speculative trading is the
way to build wealth
oh it's exhausting we'll be talking
about all that thursday evening and
again uh in two weeks on thursday the
19th in orlando
and so um
five of us some ramsey personalities
will be there rachel and george and i on
the money side dr delonia with his
number one best-selling book be there
signing it own your past change your
future he'll have some comments about
the current state of affairs
and anxiety ken coleman about the world
that we live in with hiring and careers
right now we'll be doing all of that in
las vegas on thursday tickets are a
whole 25 each you can get a four pack
for 60 dollars so uh bring up you know
like four of you get get your buddies go
out to dinner
then come over
hang out they're gonna be doing some
labs and some pre-sessions and some post
sessions and everything else and we'll
be there just working our little tail
ends off helping you guys
and for 60 bucks for four people i mean
you can't even buy pizza for that that's
not one ticket to a concert with
ticketmaster that's fees on ticketmaster
alone yeah for sure
yeah so go to ramseysolutions.com
events to get your tickets right now
and uh make sure you get all signed up
for that annie is with women
before we go to ann george um
[Music]
you can listen to this show for multiple
reasons
um
you can listen to the show for the
entertainment value because human beings
are on here and sometimes they're
laughingly entertaining sometimes
they're very sad and entertaining but
the just life happening on the radio
caller after caller that used to be what
we called the show years ago but it is
you can listen to the show for the
academic underpinnings and in other
words the actual tactical things you
learn to do
but you can also listen to the show for
life lessons
mentorship and you can even have
sometimes an anti-mentor
like whatever that person did i want to
do the exact opposite
so here's the thing poorly a young lady
just called a minute ago she's taking
that mom just just sweet
but here's the thing
for the rest of you out there
your job
as a grown-up
is to not leave your kids in that
position
now that sounds harsh or mean i'm not
being mad at her mom who's got
alzheimer's i'm not but this is just a
concept the concept is
you should have a will
get your stinking will done now
and it should include a healthcare power
of attorney which means that if you have
honest early onset this alzheimer's or
dementia and you lose the ability to
you lose your faculties to make legally
make decisions then your person who has
the power of attorney can use your money
then to take care of you they don't have
to go pay
eight thousand dollars to a lawyer to
get a judge to say you can do that
because a 15 piece of paper would have
done that
mamabearlegalforms.com hello get your
will done it's a two-page document
a healthcare power of attorney goes with
all your wills
and i'm yelling at you people that have
not done yours because 78 of americans
don't have a will
and you need your butts kicked because
you're gonna leave sweet rachel in the
lurch
and you got fifteen thousand dollars to
your name and eight thousand dollars ago
if it's going to a lawyer and it didn't
have to all you had to do was take care
of business are they scared they're
going to die earlier if they get away i
just don't i don't know there's a lot of
reasons people don't have whales one of
them is i'm afraid i'm going to die if i
get oil doofus you're going to die
nobody gets out of life okay wills do
not increase the probability of your
death it's already there hello
so oh my gosh on top of that long-term
care insurance this is something we talk
about once you're 60 years old you need
long-term care insurance and on top of
that hello you don't have to worry about
that at all
if you had been investing in saving
and stayed out of debt
and you had at 65 years old more than
fifteen thousand dollars to your name
and again i don't want you to
misunderstand i'm being harsh on that
poor lady and that poor daughter in that
situation i have my heart goes out to
them but for the if you're 35 years old
and you're like
dave ramsey and george campbell listen
you need to get your crap together
because your children are going to bear
the brunt of your misbehavior and your
irresponsibility the thing you don't
want to be when you're old is a burden
we talk about leaving a legacy on the
show and being a burden is about the
exact opposite you can be to your family
that's not how you want to go yeah
and and so it is
it's your job
to put the basic paperwork in place you
know long-term care insurance life
insurance
you you've got you know your will
and your healthcare power of attorney
and you've got um and everybody knows
what's going on and um and you save some
money well i had a hard life i
understand so have i i mean a lot of
people have had a hard life
i meet people every day that have had a
hard life and then they chose to own
their past and change their future as dr
delony says so
i i i do not you know some of you are
going to get all twisted up because you
got your little
panties in the water about everything
anyway and just go ahead and jump on
twitter and or reddit or wherever you go
to voice your crap but go ahead and do
that because you think i'm picking on
that particular lady and that particular
young lady that's taking care of her mom
both of them are sweet but i'm not mad
at either one of them but this idea that
you can walk around out there after
hearing that call
and not go fix this stuff right now
you ought to have your butt kicked
i mean really
that ought to be your inspiration you
know when i'm old i don't want to be
working at mcdonald's unless it's the
one i own in st thomas okay i mean
seriously
don't wanna be working mcdonald's period
but anyway but you see my point i don't
wanna be i don't
if you wanna be a greeter at walmart
bless you thank you
but this is not my retirement goal hello
get this stuff in order you can do it
over a lunch break people think this is
gonna it's too much time i don't want to
deal with this i get 100 a month
invested from age 25 to age 65 in a
decent growth stock mutual fund in your
roth 401k without a match dave that's
not sophisticated 100
a month is over a million dollars if you
do it from 25 to 65.
it's just simple do it
my goodness gracious you've got to get
out of
the consumption mode and out of the get
rich quick mode
and
and quit looking down your nose and just
go do the basic stuff of life
it you owe it it's how you say i love
you to your family
just imagine how much different rachel's
world would be right now if there wasn't
fifteen thousand dollars in her mom's
account but instead there was a health
care power of attorney and there was 250
000 sitting in a 401 k
oh she doesn't have to quit work now
it's a peaceful place to be
well there we go
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we talk about your life
and your money bradford and emmy are
with us
they are in salt lake city and it says
on my screen you guys are debt free
congratulations
thank you
way to go how much debt have you paid
off
252 thousand dollars wow
yeah we're super excited how long did
this take
took us about four years
and your range of income during that
time
um when we first started it was about 90
000 and then
until now is about 150. cool what do
y'all do for a living
so i am a hair stylist so i'm i work in
a salon
and i am a funeral director cool all
right and what kind of uh
what kind of debt was this
it was our house
how old are you guys
well i'm 32 and i'm 34. man i'm talking
to weird people
i know we are weird people to our
friends
you are weird people i love it what's
this house worth
i think it's about 7.50 now whoa
ding ding i love it
way to go you guys
all right how much have you got in your
uh retirements investing
uh we're probably around 200 to 250 000
as well so that like makes you baby
steps millionaires
uh yeah almost we're trying well i mean
750 and 250 is a million where i come
from
[Laughter]
okay so i think you look at you and
you're what you said you're 32
yeah and 35 32 and 35. my goodness
gracious okay so tell us the story what
happened uh four years ago at 28 and 31
that made you guys decide hey we're
paying off the house
well i think it's safe to say that i'm a
dave ramsey super fan
and so since uh since the beginning
we've always worked your baby steps
about four years ago we found this house
and and bought it using your principles
to make sure that we had as much down as
we could how much did you put down
sorry say that again how much you put
down
we put about a hundred thousand dollars
down at 24
28 years old 28 and 31 years old yeah
yes
yes sir
man that's impressive like i said super
fan for sure super fan this is like the
best day of his life calling today
well it's not a bad day for george and
me we can just tell you we like people
like you guys these guys are incredible
well thank you so you guys you
pre-decided that you were going to pay
this house off really fast
absolutely and just worked extra and
threw everything we could at it wow
george is this your cousin it must be
and they sound a lot like me these are
the kind of friends i need yeah george
yeah george's 32.
he's millionaire so you know there we go
so what inspired you guys i mean
obviously you've been a ramsay fan for a
while but what made you go hey what if
we had a paid for house in our early 30s
what would that be like
well we're really interested in
traveling and the funnest thing we've
ever done with our money has been able
to give it and share it with others and
we just want to be able to do more of
that wow so you use that as your fuel in
this journey of man we want to give more
we want to have more amazing experiences
and to do that maybe not having a
mortgage payment would help
absolutely yeah wow
so how long ago did you start doing our
our stuff bradford
um i would say about 10 years ago i
listened to you on our local radio i
bought the book i bought the
financial piece packet that had the book
the workbook and all that and i'd listen
to you as much as i could and worked it
out and
kept emmy on board and we just kept
rocking and rolling so did you guys have
debt previous to the mortgage that you
paid off or did you just kind of stay
debt-free
we just kind of stayed debt-free we did
have
debts before like we had some car
payments and
that's probably pretty much it and then
we just paid those off but yeah we've
pretty much lived we've tried to live
debt-free since you've been married
we've been married for 10 years and uh
when we very first got married is when
we jumped on board and we started our
marriage off by selling emmy's really
nice car and we never looked back since
then wow
this is what it looks like no emmy's a
32 year old millionaire so it worked out
good it worked out pretty good now i can
drive anything you want whatever i want
so
drive like no one else later you can
drive like no one else i'm so proud of
you guys you're amazing
very well yeah we're excited okay you've
been working this really for 10 years
the last four years paying off the house
been living smart wisely have you had a
life while you were doing all this or
did you just live in a cave and collect
lint and triple coupons
right we actually did have a life we
decided because i'm the spender in the
family and so i told him like we can't
live like with doing nothing agreed and
so i just so we decided to do at least
one vacation each year good um and so
that was something that we got to look
forward to
and you know plan towards but
so yeah that was kind of our motivation
to keep us have something to do fun you
know absolutely and we're looking at the
youtube pictures they're flashing on the
monitor it looks like you got three
babies during that 10 years
yeah we do have three babies that's our
greatest accomplishment amen
amen now the greatest accomplishment
will be when they have babies those are
called grand babies those are the best
things on the planet okay
i heard that
well done you guys i'm so proud of you
amazing thank you what do you think
david what do you tell people it's an
honor to talk to you and work your plan
and actually get a visit with you it's a
pretty cool accomplishment well we're
we're proud of you what do you tell
people the key to getting out of debt is
just stay the course uh of course
everyone says to do a budget and that
definitely helps and and just keep with
it keep motivated listen to the show or
do whatever it is that motivates you and
and stick with it it seems like a huge
mountain to climb but you take it step
by step you follow the baby steps and
before you know it you're on top going
look at what we can do now
unstoppable
that's just absolutely incredible you
guys very well done well we've got a
copy of baby steps millionaires for you
that is the next chapter in your story
for sure also a copy of total money
makeover for you to give away i'm sure
you've uh told a few people about this
during this decade-long journey but i'm
i thank you for that we appreciate you
spreading the word for us letting other
people know this can be done you're
proof positive you're a wonderful case
study of what it looks like if you start
this stuff and particularly if you
started early yeah it's a ten year
journey and they're now they're
millionaires just like that who is your
biggest cheerleaders guys
i would definitely say each other we
yeah we kept each other accountable we
had some good friends and we had some
friends that told us we couldn't do it
and i think that was a great motivator
as well absolutely yeah you got to have
friends like the second bunch
the ones that don't know what they're
talking about yeah i like it
they're so dumb they don't know
the haters are like free gasoline in the
tank
that's great so it's kind of nice to be
able to like yeah say thank you
and these days free gas is a big deal
right guys well done well done well done
bradford and emmy from salt lake city
utah 252
thousand dollars paid off that's their
house and everything they did that in
four years at 32 and 35 they have a 750
000 paid for home 200 700 250 000
already in their retirement plans making
them early young baby step millionaires
i'm so proud of you guys count it down
let's hear a debt free scream
three two one
[Applause]
oh man oh man we could just multiply
people like brad from an emmy across the
nation
we could uh i don't know make the
government irrelevant yeah
we really could here here's what's
interesting
okay americans last year spent 70
billion dollars
on christmas decorations
now i'm not against christmas
decorations
and i'm not against christmas papa dave
be lacking some christmas lights all
right but here's the thing
if you had a whole community full of
bradford and emmys
they could put up christmas lights
and
just a handful of them come together and
build a hospital
another handful of them come together
and feed every hungry child in the city
and another handful of them come
together
and there'd be nobody in foster care
that needed a forever home because they
pay all the adoption expenses
it wouldn't take but about a six or an
eight percent shift in giving
to completely clean up a whole lot of
the social ills that we have in america
we the people taking care of we the
people when they act like those two
be impressive that's a vision right
there this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
so
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today ann is with us in oklahoma
city hi ann how are you
hi babe thank you for all you do well
thank you how can we help today
i want to give you a scenario and my
question will be how should i best spend
almost two hundred thousand an
inheritance that i'm about to receive
and best help my retirement and not be a
burden to my children one day
and also be able to retire well here's
my scenario i'll soon be 60 years old i
was divorced in early 2021 after many
years of marriage
my net worth is approximately 600 000
excluding the 200 000 inheritance i have
no debt
out of that
out of that 600 only about 34 of that is
in retirement savings account the rest
is in rental properties and a small
business that i own
i have a fully funded emergency fund my
yearly bring home pay is approximately
ninety six thousand
five thousand of that comes from the
business each month and thirty one
hundred comes from
uh part of my teacher's retirement and
rental property income
i've been renting for a little over two
years and i've never had my own home i
would love to have a condo or a small
home
and i was wondering what the inheritance
money
should i try to buy a small condo or
home with cash if there's anything left
over invested in mutual funds
or should i forgo buying and just put
all of that 200 in mutual funds
and let it grow
um you know interest and all my concern
there is if prices keep arising will i
ever be able to afford my own little
place
or do you have a different scenario you
might recommend
well you are really on top of this
you have done a great job of knowing
where you are
and uh that tells me you really have
probably a pretty good plan of where
you're going
um how much longer do you plan to work
well you know
at least till probably 65 i mean i would
love to retire at 65 but i don't know if
that's realistic um you know 65 67 is
possible
uh you know
what kind of uh what kind of business do
you own
it's a little clothing business boutique
all right is it brick and mortar
uh yeah okay okay
well as long as it remains viable i'd
probably continue to run it as long as
you want to
um and what i would do is begin to get
more and more management involved so you
have more and more time off as you
uh go past 67. but there's no reason it
can't continue to produce an income for
you up into your 70s
okay you could sell it at some point if
you wanted to just quit
but um
my guess is what you're doing is not
that physically straining and you don't
sound like you're stressed out by it
no okay
so i i think i think i'm gonna continue
to operate as long as i can there's no
rule that says you have to quit working
at any point especially if you enjoy
what you're doing and i got a feeling
with all you've been through that it it
probably is a bit of a an escape area an
area you can go that's that you want
that you can control the variables a
safe place yes
yes it's a wonderful place you're very
grateful to be there yeah amen yeah okay
yeah i like your idea of buying
something uh small and uh putting the
rest in mutual funds buying something
that you can live in for
for cash and not having any payments
and um
are any of these rental properties a
nuisance to you would you ever want to
get rid of one
no actually um they cash flow each month
i mean that's basically how i'm living
i'm trying to keep my personal income
separate from my business income and um
so you know i don't want to get rid of
them right now
um good i'm sorry i'm a little nervous
what was your question
i just wanted to know about the rental
properties to see what the options are
but i'm with dave i'm trying to find
somewhere i can pay with cash and that's
going to reduce your expenses which
means you can live off a whole lot less
even in your retirement so that's the
goal yeah invest what would have been a
rental payment or a house payment now
here's the reason to do that
okay when you buy a piece of property
uh with
100 down obviously in this case
for your retirement years um you're 60
mathematically there's a very high
likelihood you live until 90.
average death age of a female in america
is 76 but that includes infant mortality
and teenage death and so once you're a
healthy 60 year old 90 is a high
probability statistically speaking okay
now
obviously none of us ever know exactly
we don't get to decide all that but uh
anyway so now if that means you got 30
years
from today give or take
that you are going to pay
increased rent payments every year for
30 years
it's going to go up every year
or
you're going to take your largest
expense item in your budget which is
housing
and make it stabilize or go away
right
and
the asset is going up in value
so you stabilize
the largest payment you have in your
case you're going to make it a zero but
even if you took out a house payment in
your case
you would stabilize and at least you
know you'd have the same payment
throughout the rest of your life
right and versus rent going up every
year and
the house is going up in value every
year
so that's two major reasons but it adds
a huge level of peace
and stability to be a homeowner as you
head into retirement particularly if the
home is paid for so i'm all in with you
spending
you know the vast majority of this 200
to do that and putting the rest in
mutual funds then commit what was your
old rent payment
out of your income at least if not more
into additional investing ongoing and
let's build that nest egg up yeah i love
this plan and if you have tax advantaged
retirement accounts you can do that with
i know she's a small business owner so
she's a lot of stuff she can have some
self-employed you know solo 401k or set
by ras and things of that nature yeah
you can do suppliers you can do solo
401s that's exactly right and do a roth
and do all of it and put it all in
mutual funds and just see how rich you
can become in the next 10 years
i'll bet you you could have a million
and a half in 10 years in mutual funds
i'll bet you you could get there without
a single house payment in the world
making a hundred thousand dollars a year
i'll bet you it could be done and have a
decent life while you're doing it and
those rentals will go up in value over
time as well and those rents coming to
you not
going to someone else i like this plan
this is going up so just like your
investments go up that is an investment
and those rental
uh
values will go up as well connor is with
us connor is in pittsburgh hi connor how
are you i'm good dave how are you better
than i deserve what's up
all right so my question is kind of a
long-term um question about bridge
investing so my situation is i just
turned 26 i make 50 dollars a year i
have thirty thousand dollars in a
brokerage account twenty thousand
dollars and roth iras and 401k
i have a house that is valued at two
hundred and fifty thousand i owe 127 000
on it you don't need to worry about
bridge money right now
well so the reason i'm asking that is i
had a conversation with my mom
and she is deciding that she's going to
pay the house off for me oh within the
next within the next year or so
um
and so
so i wanted to know
you know my family's done well in real
estate grandparents and parents and such
and so i've kind of always leaned that
way but i have cerebral palsy
and uh i've seen this it takes a lot
physically to care for a bunch of rental
properties no it doesn't if you hire
somebody to do it
yeah so that was my that was part of my
question was would you just hire a
management company or is there some
other
way you would do it yeah but you got to
ride herd on them but that's an
intellectual uh process not a lifting a
hammer or concrete block process
so you have to watch them and make sure
they don't charge you eight hundred
dollars
for a water heater that should have been
four hundred dollars
okay yeah i can definitely definitely
handle that and make sure that they're
actually paying attention when the house
is empty and getting filled back up is
there a sign in the yard are they
keeping the grass cut the bushes trim so
the house is marketable when it turns
over so you got to watch your property
still but you don't have to do the
physical lifting and the day-to-day
negotiating and dealing with tenants
you'll be just fine with that so if
you're saving up to buy some pro
buy some rentals for cash i'll be fine
with that after mom pays off your house
that'd be pretty cool
put you in a really good situation well
mom that's really cool but that does not
mean you need to do bridge investing
exclusively you need to do
all you can put into retirement and
you'll still without a house payment
have room to do some bridge investing
that you can turn into some paid for
real estate
so very cool
good question and good clarification
thanks this is the ramsey show
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people to build wealth
do work that they love
and have amazing actual
relationships george campbell ramsey
personality is my co-host today as we
answer your questions about your life
and your money this is a show
all about you and george you know what
happens
if you walk the baby steps you become a
millionaire yeah
and you know what's worse
oh boy what could be worse than that
well you became a millionaire which by
definition
makes you a terrible person you're a
terrible person rich people are evil
greedy rich people i read that on
twitter recently greedy rich people are
evil and they're everywhere
and we're trying to make more of them
that's our problem
we're awful we want you to be not greedy
but we do want you to be rich people
and outrageously generous rich people
but the greedy rich people are
everywhere
and they're out there
doing greedy rich people stuff and
they're giving
greedy rich people a bad name when they
do this because i mean how can you
say let's triple the tax rate on the
rich because they don't do anything
except consume
the only way they get their money is to
inherit it we have to tell lots of lies
about the rich we have to vilify success
in order to make socialism the way to go
in america it's what we've been working
on for a while now and this whole greedy
rich people
syndrome it's just spreading and like
our producer handed us this apparently
ashton kutcher and milo kunis
i think it's ashton kutcher and mila
kunis i think milo am i right james okay
james is hip he knows pop culture i
don't i know who ashton kutcher was
because he punks some people once but
other than that
i don't want a great
reference you know the problem they've
done now is apparently
mila is from the ukraine
and uh these guys these gritty rich
people they went and raised over 34
million dollars to help
in humanitarian aid in the ukraine
temporary housing for the refugees
according to the couple's gofundme page
okunis was born in ukraine in 1983 moved
to the united states when she was eight
years old she says ukrainians are proud
and brave people who deserve our help in
their time of need and so these greedy
rich people she and ashton they got
together with some other greedy rich
people
and made a bunch of donations the nerve
i can't believe they helped people with
their money that's awful they're giving
a bad name to the greedy rich people
so uh uh mila and ashton created the
fundraising page mark march third made a
personal donation
see here they here they they and then
they told people they did it so they're
just awful they three million dollars
they put in their own money
then more than 65 000 donors have
contributed to the campaign the list of
top contributors includes some of the
world's greediest wealthiest individuals
billionaire larry ellison the chairman
of oracle uh he donated 5 million
because he's a greedy rich guy
silicon valley
private equity firm dst global greedy
rich people they contributed three
million dollars
and the family foundation of dst partner
yuri milner gave another two and a half
million dollars
uh so that's like man that's like five
and a half million dollars from the dst
group alone but they're all gritty rich
people we know about that
uh another two and a half million
donation came from the family of
renowned silicon valley angel investor
ron conway fashion model uh carl uh is
it carly kloss i think it's close close
thank you well i'm not that happy i'm
i'm one degree hipper this is a fashion
model which is two things i don't know
anything about fashion or models so uh
josh
josh kushner uh donated 250 000 through
his foundation he's a venture capitalist
another one of those greedy rich people
and so uh we're overwhelmed with
gratitude for this support from the
greedy rich people said ashton kutcher
didn't say the last part i added it and
in an instagram post on march 17th our
collective greedy rich people effort
will provide a softer landing for many
people as they forge ahead to their
future of uncertainty humanitarian aid
temporary housing for ukrainian refugees
brought to you by
greedy rich people wow
and i'm on the site now i'm looking at
the gofundme they're up to over 36
million dollars with over almost 76 000
donations precisely more than 36 million
36 million dollars more than the us
government has given oh yeah to help
ukrainian refugees
exactly to the penny
and um so your tax dollars
wait not at work okay there we go okay
and instead individuals private
individuals who have wealth
uh were outrageously generous i mean
they were greedy rich people
and uh
took care of people in another part of
the world that they don't even know that
they never even met that they just
thought you know these people need
humanitarian aid they need temporary
housing uh the largest refugee crisis in
the history of mankind by the way
more people displaced than in any other
refugee crisis ever in history wow
you haven't heard that on the news
those are actual numbers i didn't make
that up
and uh pretty incredible and we're all
just um
but the gritty rich people they're doing
something about disgusting and inspiring
did the broke people send money
you know i it doesn't say is there a
broke people page i don't think that's
on here but i guess broke you know if
there's a broken people go fundamentally
donate page yeah you can donate as
little as you can put the change out of
every dollar that you don't use and so
you could send a nickel or seven cents
or
you know that kind of stuff and i'm sure
it'll change their life
but the greedy rich people dropped in 36
million so um they went first just
wanted you to know that those people are
out there and they're horrible
and
you know we don't we don't we don't
endorse that kind of generosity because
it gives greedy rich people a bad name
we're here to make them look good not
bad do you recognize the sarcasm font in
my voice i hope so although some people
listening may not understand it
well the hang around you'll get it after
a while
well it's very cool i'm i'm excited
about this well james came up with this
idea our producer he said every so often
we should just feature some of the
horrible things that the greedy rich
people are doing it's important to shine
a light on it so it's yeah i mean they
should be exposed
they should be exposed for what they do
they're just awful it's horrible that
the human beings could be kind to each
other and use dollars to do it it's
disgusting after having earned a living
in capitalism in the greatest land that
amen that the world has ever known
called america
and these people have made money more
money than they've ever dreamed of and
they gave away more money than most of
you ever dreamed of in this one
transaction
but they're greedy rich people and they
sh they should pay their fair share of
taxes well they're probably doing this
for tax evasion purposes tax evasion
that's what it is because of course
if you give away
two million dollars it saves you three
hundred thousand on your taxes that's
how that works
good math maybe
maybe less depending on your situation
because you're when you're a greedy rich
person with a huge income like that the
amount of your charitable deductions
that you can deduct goes down
on a scale to where at some point you
get almost no tax deduction for your
charitable contributions so
of course that's mathematically how tax
evasion works we're not doing math here
dave i'm just here to get riled up we
want to let you know that greedy rich
people they don't pay taxes either
you've cleared the air for sure
not at all
because people are still confusing which
is sarcasm and which isn't but oh well
we'll get there eventually turn off the
sarcasm font dave so myla or mila i'm
sorry darling i don't know your name and
ashton we salute you
we salute all of your friends
and we salute your generosity
thank you for giving gritty rich people
a bad name
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
health care coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business check us out at
chministries.org backslash budget we
absolutely believe in it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five garrett is in
phoenix arizona hi garrett welcome to
the ramsey show
hey dave how you doing better than i
deserve what's up
well i was calling in because so i was
just laid off on thursday oh i'm in the
mortgage three
what happened i'm 12 years old um
yeah good question my whole department
was like also a little over a hundred of
us so they just they're not doing enough
mortgages
yeah correct yeah so we just we do
direct to consumer and they're just
revising off the market yeah
and the reviews have slowed down because
people can't get houses there's no
inventory right exactly
they laid 100 people off what kind of
what were you doing in the mortgage
business
um i ran a process into
you're a processor okay operation yeah
okay so
where i'm at is
um
thanks to you guys um i my dad as well i
started
i never had that really um
i got about a year of reserve set aside
so i don't have that stress i'm working
on getting back into the workplace you
know interviewing applying
but for the last few months i've been
working on starting my own
processing company a contract processing
firm um i'm pretty dang close i have my
tests in a couple of days
um taking my license for that so you saw
the writing on the wall
yeah
yeah i've been preparing since about
november um
i stopped investing everything and just
started pack pucking money away in my
six month reserve account
and just
loaded it up since i had a feeling
things were gonna start turning okay if
they laid off a hundred people because
there's no mortgages to process how are
you gonna make money running a contract
processing firm
and so that's part of my that's part of
the so
so i have two contracts already with
brokers that i've worked with in the
past um
that are ready to execute on those
contracts that 15 loans a month for both
of them so 30 loans right out the gate
which would then replace my salary and
money pretty much instant daily
instantaneously
um
my i guess my real question is
so
should i still kind of go that route
since i have the money to do so and or
and the security's there i mean i don't
have that concern necessarily um or
should i just be trying to get back into
the
you know the corporate side
and you know keep interviewing apply get
a job there and then kind of postpone
this plan until things kind of
shimmer down maybe a bit i guess i'm
just trying to clarify or figure out
should i take this self-employed style
role or go back into corporate america
sounds like you got enough of the
pipeline self-employed to make it sweet
what's wrong with the what's wrong with
it
um
i would say the biggest thing is we just
my wife and i just had a baby um in
december
and the fear is more there so she just
stopped working two weeks ago ironically
um but you have enough to replace your
salary in the pipeline
correct so my big concern is that
as things continue to
i i guess be unsteady in a way you know
with inventory and there were rates
my fear is that the fee sales teams are
not going to be producing the same they
were they they're they're confident and
they're telling me they're all you know
they're good yeah but could you go get
more contracts other than can you go get
more contracts other than these two
um yeah so that's that's kind of what
i'm working on and but the problem with
that currently is i need to
get you know licensed and actually
operational first which i have the test
tomorrow so that's that'll be happening
in the next couple of days obviously so
how quickly could you be running this
business
and producing an income um
six weeks or less okay
i mean it sounds like there's some fear
that this may not work and so if you
want to do something you know part-time
for now just to make sure that you've
got the income there but you said you
have a year of reserves you got a year
emergency fund sitting there
uh yeah i got 39 000 sitting in my
reserve account and you've got no debt
and so i feel like your risk is
pretty low
uh yeah so i mean we live on about 2700
a month
um i had my mortgage on a 15 year and
got my payment to about 1200 bucks
um so
i've got a low mortgage payment low
housing costs in general how old are you
old car 22
22 wow
yes sir wow okay i thought i was talking
to a 32 year old way to go dude you're
you're poised
you carry yourself well all right um
can i can i just tell you what i think
i'm hearing and then you tell me if i'm
wrong okay yes sir
i think i'm hearing
this is why i asked how old you were by
the way
i think i'm hearing
that you are making the mistake
that a corporate job is secure
and self-employment is not
100 i would agree with that that is a
mistake you've just discovered last
thursday
that corporate is not safe
as a matter of fact it is less safe than
self-employed because self-employed is
you have to get up my man
leave the cave kill something and drag
it home every day you're under no
illusions
of who's in charge of your destiny
when you're waiting on corporate america
to just keep writing you a check
meanwhile they can't even balance their
checkbook in the back room
so they just swoop in one thursday and
go 100 of you go home
with no more heart than an armadillo has
which has a very small heart by the way
and so um you know there you go
so no i i do not want to be beholden to
corporate america for anything if i can
help it uh if you want to it's okay but
don't do it under the name under the
heading of
uh
security because it's not secure
right okay that doesn't make sense and
you're right you're a human
which means when you bring another human
onto the planet in your early 20s it
scares the crap out of you which means
you're going to be a great dad
all right because you're actually a
responsible guy
so what did you make is what did you
make before how much money were you
making
um
so my base pay was 80 000 and bonuses
were between 62 like 120 a year okay you
you can go you can go make that kind of
money again doing a lot of different
things as sharp as you are
fairly quickly if this processing thing
goes belly up on you
okay don't lose your entire everything
holding on too tightly to the processing
idea but if you can get it out there and
get it running and make a living doing
it keep it open and keep poking around
the edges of it until you get enough
contracts that get stable because see
when you were working for that other
company you had one customer
if you had 10 customers you'd be more
stable
yeah that's a that's a that's very true
actually yeah that's actually exciting
to look at that but with your work ethic
you can go anywhere in the financial
industry and i'm not worried about you
producing an income if this
self-employment doesn't work out yeah
you'll be able to land something before
your money runs out
and uh you're the kind of guy that go
deliver pizzas at night if you had to or
do whatever until you landed the you
know the paying quote j-o-b again job
career whatever direction you're going
there but if i'm in your shoes dude i'm
just going to uh as an act of my will
not in a rash way or an unwise way but
i'm going to override my security gland
here my
my insecurity because i have a brand new
baby and i just got fired
and i didn't see it coming and i didn't
do anything wrong
and that's enough to scare anybody any
age
but you're a young dude with a young
family and it not just not it kicks you
in the kneecap emotionally which just
means that you're a guy that cares
you're a person of honor you're a good
husband you're a good dad you're gonna
be awesome man we need more sharp 22
year olds like garrett out there it'd
give me a lot of faith in the economy we
we have them there there
but obviously corporate america doesn't
appreciate them
so um there you go but you can't pay the
bill you can't pay the bill i guess so
you lay the people off but um
that's how some of the best businesses
are started something like this goes i'm
gonna do it on my own that's exactly
right
never again am i gonna be put in a
situation where i'm dependent on someone
else to feed my family i'm gonna get up
leave the cave kill something and drag
it home every day and you're right
that's exactly how a lot of the entree
leadership people that we meet with
they're um sometimes what we call
accidental entrepreneurs they like find
themselves unemployed they go well i've
just been making this thing in the
basement so let's go make a bunch of
them and suddenly they're millionaires
making a bunch of them they solved the
problem made some customers happy didn't
didn't have an intention of being in
business but there they were
and uh found it to be much more secure
and much more rewarding than working for
corporate america that's the american
spirit there we go i love it long as
there are garages there will be small
business and as long as there is small
business
there will always be capitalism
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
america in the lobby of ramsey solutions
which by the way you can visit anytime
you'd like and watch the show we uh do a
live show every afternoon from one to
four central time regardless of when you
guys hear it that's when it actually
occurs
and if you'd like to come by and watch
the show and we're often taping uh
podcasts and so forth in the morning on
the glass as well the dr deloney show
the ken coleman show all of that there's
free cookies free coffee and it's really
smells like cookies and mama's kitchen
in here and there's a bookstore at a
full visitor center come visit us
anytime we'd love to have you there's
usually 50 to 200 folks out here
watching the show and it's completely
free we'd love to have you and just come
in and say hi but on the debt-free stage
right here in said lobby is brad and
tamara hi guys how are you guys good
good how are you better than i deserve
how much debt have you paid off a little
over a hundred thousand dollars good how
long did that take about 18 months good
for you and your range of income during
that time uh 109 000 at the beginning
and now we are at 151 000. good good
what do you guys do for a living i'm a
cardiovascular sonographer
and i work in the oil and gas uh design
helping design gas plants oh wow good
okay where do you all live um
bartlesville oklahoma which is near
tulsa tulsa oklahoma okay good good well
welcome to nashville and congratulations
thank you what kind of debt was the
hundred thousand um a little bit of
everything so car payments student loans
truck payments track payment
uh taxes
y'all were normal
right yeah normal sucks yes wasn't any
fun you're making a lot of money and all
going back out to somebody else oh yeah
what was the wake-up call 18 months ago
what what jogged you
well we shortly got married shortly
before that we got married and my
parents actually
paid to have us go to dave ramsey um fpu
and uh we started it and then about a
couple months into it we uh
wound up i lost my job oh my gosh and
then she got furloughed the day after oh
man all thanks to copenhagen yeah oh
okay
happy marriage yeah right yeah
and then about three months later i
wound up getting a job back in the oil
and gas industry
was there for about seven months and
then got furloughed again
went back to the place that i originally
got let go from and uh
did contract work for about a year and
now i'm back there they brought me back
on full time wow
that's been a full circle yeah i've been
a lot been a wild ride there oh yeah
okay so i gotta go back though to the
beginning of the story so
we get married
and brad's mom and dad
buy a financial class
so tamara how thrilled were you with
that at all
i'm definitely the free spirit
i'm not even gonna lie i love it
that wouldn't have gone well at my house
what did you think was the underlying
reason they gifted this to you
uh just to be financially stable and to
be successful i was like i don't want to
deal with all of this i was like i want
to go spend my money
okay so you got you're brand new married
and
before you get laid off you wander into
this class
and tamara how long were you there
before you went you know i think i can
actually do this it took me a little bit
to get on board i'm not gonna maybe
a couple of months probably oh way down
into the class then yeah wow yeah was
there a moment what was the thing that
when you went all right fine i'm in um
just knowing that i wouldn't have to
have all of my paycheck go to somebody
else
that
in that way so i want my kids to be
raised in that way where they don't have
to worry there you go start thinking
about something big like changing your
family tree exactly yeah that's a the
noble motivations are the strongest
motivations by the way you're right
that's exactly right
very very cool stuff and brad you go in
there um and i got a feeling if she's
the free spirit you're the nurse yeah
and so you're there for about 10 minutes
and you went yeah i see what mom was
doing
exactly yeah yeah that's how it was okay
all right it's hard to keep your mouth
shut about get you in trouble yes yeah
yeah yeah yeah this is that's classic
yeah i love it i love it wow all right
so what was the most important thing
that you guys learned while you're going
through financial peace university that
enabled you to pay off a hundred
thousand dollars in 18 months
while being furloughed and then back to
work and then being furloughed and then
back to work and then contracting and
then back to work and then oh my gosh
just discipline and communication
yeah just working together
work together and to accomplish those
goals wow so you guys haven't been
married too long now has it changed your
marriage
oh yeah yeah i'd say so yeah yep it's
more on the same page oh yeah oh yes
definitely
and i assume you had some cheerleaders
in this process obviously brad's parents
they're pumped yeah oh yeah and the kids
were too so and then the financial
coaches that we had at city church uh
jason and janet uh
they uh
we met with them we still talk to them
to this day and they
still encourage us to keep pushing
forward
yeah they're walking around real proud
right now that you're here
that's why they do this stuff i love it
that's so cool y'all well done very well
done what was the hardest part for you
sticking to the budget sticking to the
budget
what's your big temptation to get off
budget
close close
that makes sense i'm not gonna lie no
that's good i'm in i'm yeah
rachel cruz would completely agree with
you
it's actually eating out
eating out usually gets most people that
one people don't realize in america how
much we spend on that i'm not against
restaurants but uh
but you know by the time you spend all
that you ought to own one oh my gosh i
mean yeah
and it's about 80 of that check is for
the experience not the food you can buy
that much food for 20 cents on the
dollar cook it at home and uh and have a
pretty good meal yeah so wow well way to
go you guys way to go are you glad you
did all that oh yeah lately yep yep you
ever go back in debt no no not even for
clothes not even for clothes
now it's time to save for a new house
there you go all right you renting or
you own one uh we own one right now but
you need to move up a little yeah yeah
because both of our kids are in one room
right now oh yeah sharing bunk beds and
we gotta get a little bit bigger it's a
bonding experience oh yes
that's good that needs to end yes
[Laughter]
i like it well way to go you guys we're
very proud of you thank you for coming
over here and sharing your story thank
you it's a great way to start out a
brand new marriage and get things going
way to go very very well done
all right and uh very cool very cool we
got a copy of uh baby steps millionaires
for you that is the next chapter in your
story for sure and a copy of the total
money makeover book to give away and
maybe you could be kind of like uh your
mother-in-law and just stir up a ruckus
with somebody you know you never know
there all right good stuff
all right it's pretty cool this is this
is great brad and tamara from tulsa
hundred thousand dollars paid off in 18
months making 109 to 151 count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one we're debt-free
[Applause]
that is how it's done boys and girls
i love it
so uh yeah it's that's a delicate gift
for a mother-in-law to give uh to a new
couple yeah gifting fpu feels like it's
an underhanded backhanded passive
aggressive gift
passive-aggressive statement hey you're
broke this should help thanks so much
thank you thanks but when you can accept
that gift and actually do the stuff dave
you're looking a little pudgy here's a
book on dieting exactly that's exactly
what it's like that is the last gift i'm
going to give you dave hudgy that's a
word you don't hear much no bring it
back
that's a word that should come back
because it actually applies so
eating out i realized dave when i was
getting out of debt i was spending 700
on food look at me where do you even put
700 in food where do you put 700 i mean
that's the question
but it's amazing when you start paying
attention to the stuff and you go oh my
gosh what am i doing it's you you're
kind of disgusted with yourself when you
look in the mirror but george has a you
you have a real
i mean you have a high palate on food i
mean the fine dining experience that is
true you're kind of known for the chef's
tasting menu and well me and rachel call
it bougie
that's what we are
you don't do that on the job do you no
no absolutely not you don't do boozy on
the job well you guys made us bougie
here at ramsey or there's charcuterie
everywhere i didn't even know what that
word meant before i worked here no it's
everywhere now that's how we live
it's a good life
baby it's a good life paid for in cash
free salami
that's right from lunchables to
charcuterie that's the american dream
we made it mom we made it touchdown this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today here on the ramsey show
thank you for joining us america triple
eight eight two five five
two two five
dave i gotta say one of my favorite
things and you know this about me it's a
spiritual gift i love to give away your
money
it's my favorite type of generosity
you're one of those greedy rich people
i'm one of those and uh that's why i'm
excited to tell all of our listeners
about our ramsay cash giveaway that we
just launched today five hundred dollars
every single week we're giving away and
a grand prize of three thousand dollars
it's amazing even with inflation we're
still giving away money all in the month
of may
and uh hey if you think about all the
things you could do with some extra cash
you could pay off debt you could have a
fun night out you could finally start a
side hustle add it to your investments
there's a lot of good stuff if you want
to enter the giveaway go to
ramseysolutions.com
giveaway you can enter every day for
more chances to win no purchases
necessary you got to be 18.
while you're there um you need to check
out at the store the 10
book sale that's going on we're putting
a whole bunch of our number one
best-selling books and tools in the
ramsey ten dollar sale and that means
the total money makeover which is now
sold over eight million copies is on the
best seller list almost every week still
um the uh is only ten dollars people buy
them by the case they buy rachel's book
by the case coleman's book by the case
uh christie's book uh take back your
time is ten dollars um the questions for
human car humans questions for humans
conversation cards now only ten dollars
that's the uh dr john delaney uh product
that we have sold
bajillions tens of thousands of them
it's just a biz yeah yeah thank you yeah
appreciate you guys 10 bucks uh all the
10 sales stuff happening at
ramseysolutions.com right now while
you're there not for ten dollars you can
pick up the brand new number one
bestseller from dr john doloni we found
out late last week it is a number one
national bestseller on several of the
lists
so thank you for that
awesome own your past change your future
a not so complicated approach to
relationships mental health and
wellness so all of that at
ramseysolutions.com
kent is in tampa hi kent welcome to the
ramsey show
hi dave and george thank you so much for
having me sure what's up
um basically i'm looking for uh
permission to pursue my dreams
i'm a stage manager
in live entertainment mostly working in
cruise ships theme parks and regional
theaters but ultimately i want to work
on broadway musicals and national tours
but obviously to do that i have to live
in new york
and that would be a significant increase
in living expenses and i just wanted to
see if there was sort of a benchmark
that you would suggest hitting before
making that jump i'm 25 years old i have
no debt i have a fully funded actually
an overfunded emergency fund
um but moving to new york would
basically take out all of the margin i
could make it work but it would take out
all of the margin but it would also open
up uh
a lot more earning potential so i just
wanted to get your thoughts i know it
would be risky but i just want to make
sure it's not stupid and i figured if
anyone is going to be willing to tell me
that it's stupid it would be dave
[Laughter]
well ken you've done a great job so far
i don't i this is not the riskiest move
you could make at 25 years old with no
debt in an emergency fund that is
overfunded so you're going to be okay
this sounds like this is your dream this
is what you want to do and so i'm making
the move now you want to do it with some
wisdom can you line up a job there or is
this one of those show up do whatever it
takes work at a coffee shop and try to
make this dream happen
uh it's closer to that i have a pretty
good network so i feel like it would
definitely when something becomes
available i would have people that i
could reach out to but it's sort of you
have to you have to be there in order to
get the job kind of thing
you set your life up to where you'd be
there in 20 minutes
and you can get from tampa to new york
in an hour and a half two hours
tampa in new york city
you can jump on an airplane and get up
there in a couple hours okay
so yeah
it's not like you
um
i mean i think you start working your
network and you get something to line up
and if they want you to come up there
and interview one day fly up there an
interview and when you land the job then
make the move i i um i might stay in
tampa till i kept and keep my lifestyle
costs way down because your cost of
living there is probably 70 cents on the
dollar what it is in manhattan
yeah at least
i mean a rent is more than that but the
rest of the cost of living is probably
70 cents on the dollar so um
and you know if you could and you've got
work there that's not a coffee shop
right i don't care i'm with georgia go
do it if you want to go do it the
lead the way to lower the risk one more
time is to get a whole bunch of stuff
almost dripping out in the pipeline and
then make the move then right now it
sounds like you're just going up there
hoping you can fill the pipeline
yeah i don't know if it would make a
difference in what you would suggest but
a lot of the work that i do um takes me
out of town and they provide housing and
everything so a lot of the work that i
currently am doing i could still
continue to do
um in new york it just wouldn't
necessarily be jobs that are in new york
if that makes sense yeah okay all right
so you could keep working while your
current a lot of your current gigs while
you look for the new york break
yes so the only difference here is just
the relocation
precisely definitely doing that head on
baby do it
great well thank you so much i
appreciate it and if you reach the point
that you're going in debt to keep your
dream alive and you're getting ready to
turn your dream into a nightmare move
back
oh for sure
but you know the trip the trick is
you've got the margin here and you've
learned how to look at this with a
critical eye which you already did
before you called us
so i'm with george there's your
permission yeah
well number one you don't need our
permission you're like a grown man and
stuff so but there's your advice anyway
um sometimes they need a little
confirmation we don't give permission
here we just give advice and then you
make you give yourself permission
because you're like grown-ups and things
so
but uh we'll get we'll think it through
with you and think you you know see if
you're missing something and
uh or maybe make some additional
suggestions that might be wrong or
whatever and then you still got to make
your own decisions oh yeah but he sounds
like he's doing it with some wisdom here
yeah yeah i like it go for it baby go
for it wide open man chad's in san diego
hi chad how are you
hi doing very well um
i just want to say grandpa dave and good
friend george thank you very much for
having me you're welcome
so my father passed away and
uh passed away last week
he was in charge of our family business
oh my gosh and also my family as well as
of course
my family currently is okay so i have a
core crisis team taking care of them
that thankfully brought together a great
team um so we're on a survival mode on
family side and business side
families should be okay to fight for
another month but our business currently
i believe we really need help on that
side
for business
my question is
is there a survival mode type setting
that i should focus on
for our business to continue on how many
team members
um majority of it is our family so i
think about 12. what kind of what kind
of business
i would say we do a lot of retail and
servicing
it's that's how our build business is
kind of structured retail and servicing
a lot
um i would say maybe home appliance type
things okay and then we have a lot of
debt as well but i'm trying to just
focus on just survival mode what should
we focus on okay your dad's estate has a
lot of debt you don't have any debt
right the business had the business debt
was in his name
and his estate is the is is what
supports that debt so if you guys can
keep the business operating you'll pay
the business debt out of the business as
a part of his estate but you don't need
to pay in these payments
right neither does your brother or your
cousin
right however because my mom's name is
on the business how can i best help her
or like try to protect her yeah well
you're gonna you know you're gonna keep
running the business and get the debt
paid off or you're gonna sell the
business and pay the debt off
one of the two
that's what you're going to do so um
this is a
large and complicated question
more than i can probably help you
adequately with in a two-minute radio
call like this i'm so sorry for your
loss by the way what happened to it
thank you so much
so um
i believe it was just his heart stopped
and we don't really have much details
since it's still very new
i'm sorry um here's what here's what
we're gonna do brother i'm gonna put you
on hold kelly's gonna pick up we're
gonna hook you up with one of our entree
leadership business coaches
we've got business coaches in entree
leadership and one of them will help you
walk through and help you analyze
a how to keep it operating in crisis
mode until you can make some management
transitions or and or b until you can
sell it whichever you guys choose to do
it's still very very fresh with him just
being gone a week i'm so sorry
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw
as the status symbol of choice george
campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today
as we answer your questions about
building wealth doing work that you love
creating amazing high quality
relationships
this is the ramsey show the phone number
is triple eight eight two five
five two two five deb starts off this
hour in des moines iowa hi deb how are
you
hi dave yes this is deb my husband and i
were basic followers of the dave ramsey
way
we always had one difference
he kept wanting in his 40s and 50s to
stock money away for retirement i wanted
to pay the mortgage off our mortgage was
at a very low rate
so he thought we'd be better off paying
the mortgage
and
earning that retirement money getting it
in those iras and stuff at
a higher interest rate
so my one concession was okay before you
retire then at age 60 and he retired at
62
we're going to pay off that home or home
mortgage which we did
so he retired at 62
were you know
everyday millionaires
i'm going to retire this year at
63. my 40 year old son is getting
married for the first time i told him
and his fiancee my one regret was we did
not pay off our mortgage sooner
and my son's coming back at me with that
same argument mom why would i pay off
the mortgage when i have a low interest
rate
if i can make more money putting
the money into
investment
so dave what
can i tell them
well it's going to be hard to convince
him against his will i mean you can give
him some tools resources has he is he
does he know about the ramsey plan
basically he does and beyond his home
mortgage he has no other debt okay yeah
we we hear this argument a lot and it
looks good on paper but we found that
when you actually do this stuff and when
you survey all these millionaires with
paid for homes
none of them are going you know what i
kind of miss my mortgage i want to go
back into debt and when he frees up that
mortgage payment guess what he can do
now invest way more than he was
so
for sure
okay does your husband
think that he is now an everyday
baby steps millionaire
because he
didn't pay off the house and invested
the money
does he think that's how he became a
millionaire
that's a good question i've never asked
him yeah
because i i think he would tell you
that's that's not how he became a
millionaire
the way he became a millionaire was he
steadily invested and he controlled his
expenses
and that enabled him to not only become
a millionaire but also pay off the house
which added to
the process
so the the answer to the question is
number one you're not going to tell a 40
year old anything
you know
he's going to do whatever he wants to do
so george is right my grandmother's
saying applies those convinced against
their will are of the same opinion still
if he actually does want to engage a
conversation which it doesn't sound like
he does it sounds like you do
but if he does except his girlfriend or
her fiance
she kind of took my side
she did oh
okay so we're having a good healthy fun
family argument like the ramsays do
every meal okay yeah i probably do we
all we all argue with rachel about our
conspiracy theories at every meal so
okay
all right so um
you gotta have some fun right so uh
exactly well the answer to the question
or the answer to the argument is several
fold okay
um i i have approached it in my life
from about three or four different
angles
and every one of those angles has led me
to pay off the house the first angle i
approached it from
once i went broke with borrowed money on
real estate
um i i was a baby christian and i
couldn't find anything in the bible that
said anything good about debt you're a
fool you're a slave
um it's unwise it's not a salvation
issue spiritually and it's not a uh
it's um
certainly not even a sin
biblically but every mention of debt in
the bible is negative so as a person of
faith i had to say okay my heavenly
father says this is a dumb idea
biblically speaking dead is stupid okay
why would he say that because he loves
me if the best way to become wealthy is
to borrow on your house and then take
that money and invest in the stock
market okay so that first step is i
entered it through that argument then
the next argument i entered into was
this idea of risk
debt
equals risk i think we can all agree to
that more debt equals more risk less
debt equals less risk no debt equals
virtually no risk
and so
and you can tell that by when you say
okay if borrowing against your house
at three percent or five percent and
investing it in the market in a mutual
fund a ten percent rate of return 12
rate of return whatever i'm making that
spread
if that is an accurate mathematical
formula why would you not
borrow
300 000 on a 100 000 house you would
borrow all you can up to your eyeballs
if you're always going to make
a seven or an eight percent spread right
right but when you ask somebody well why
don't you borrow two million dollars
that way then that put that puts them in
freak out mode because when you put the
absurd on the table no way it makes your
emotions kick in and your emotions are
where you experience risk not in your
intellect
so your heart is where you feel risk
your head is where you do math
and so your heart goes your heart starts
beating like oh god no
well that's because now suddenly you're
equating risk with debt and in his
discussion he's got the debt small
enough in his mind that he doesn't
equate it to risk follow me
right so
all of that to say that in sophisticated
financial circles which your son doesn't
run in
they we actually are taught to adjust a
risky investment
with an unrisky investment or a low risk
investment with a high risk investment
was actually a mathematical process for
adjusting those two for risk to where
you can compare them apples to apples so
the high risk investment after adjusted
for risk the rate of return would come
down the low risk investment after
adjusted for risk would come up and then
you could compare them apples to apples
and there's just a statistical measure
of risk called a beta which is the
measure of the hill in the valley and
the frequency of the hill in the valley
and when you put it on a chart this
measures risk
if you entered that and you actually
used a real math formula for your your
son's
naive math formula that's incorrect
then you said okay we're taking on more
risks so we can't really count the
entire spread
from the mortgage rate up to the market
rate as spread because we have to adjust
for risk and we adjust for risk it
neutralizes the benefit of the borrowed
money
there's your academic answer
i gave you a spiritual answer academic
answer okay now let me give you one more
the borrower's slave to the lender
so that must mean
slaves think differently
they have different relationships
because they're not in control of their
lives they keep a job they wouldn't keep
otherwise i can't quit this job i have a
house payment i can't tell the boss to
take this job and shove it
in a toxic low integrity situation i
have to keep the job because i have a
house payment so you keep a bad job with
a bad boss
until it ends up caving in on your head
and you end up making less in your life
because you're forced into stuff
like slaves are
you make more money you have better
relationships you take less risk and you
make money faster if you don't have a
mortgage your son is so wrong it's
unbelievable this is the ramsey shaft
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free homeownership and churchill is
here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today you hear me say all the
time that everyone needs a will and it's
true it's a basic adult responsibility
there's just no good excuse not to have
one
you've also heard us recommend an online
will as the fastest most cost effective
way to get your will taken care of
but i get a lot of questions about a
simple online will is that right for
everyone's specific situation i get that
what if you need a trust or you need a
mirror will or what kind of powers of
attorney do you need with those
questions in mind our team built a quiz
to help you find the right option do you
need a
mamabearlegalforms.com well online or do
you need an attorney we'll tell you we
don't mind telling you we want you to
get the right thing in your situation
after taking this quick easy free quiz
we'll direct you to the way you need to
go but either way you're going to end up
with a will at the end of the story okay
take the quiz to figure out what kind of
will you need go to ramseysolutions.com
will's quiz
wills quiz and that's not with an
apostrophe because will didn't do the
quiz but it's a wills quiz to check it
out for yourself
ramsey solutions dot com slash wheels
quiz our question today comes from
blinds.com they have a 100 satisfaction
guarantee that means even if you
mismeasure you pick the wrong color
they'll remake your blinds for free
you'll get free samples free shipping
and with the new promos they run every
month you'll save even more use the
promo code ramsey to get the best
possible deal today's question comes
from debbie in los angeles she said my
husband and i have 230 000 dollars in
our 401k we switched to a money market
plan about seven years ago because we're
both in our mid-50s good lord the cfo at
his work is now trying to convince him
to go back into mutual funds he went as
far as to tell him that we missed out on
59 000 in 2021 he's right i'm not buying
it we lost almost all of our 401k in
2008 with this man telling us it would
go back up and to stop watching it
i don't want to ever watch that train
wreck again why would the cfo be pushing
for us to risk
our retirement fund
oh boy where to start with debbie sweet
debbie sweden little debbie a little bit
all right well little debbie's got a
cake
uh i'm with the cfo on this one i think
he's trying to help you retire with
dignity and not lose out big because you
jumped off the roller coaster mid-ride
and clearly their spook day from 2008
which is understandable but to be in a
money market account which means it's
just sitting in cash for seven years
losing against inflation making zero
percent that's a bad plan if you want to
retire ever
all right debbie
you can't win at investing being drama
debbie
and you're being drama debbie you did
not lose your entire 401k in 2008. the
stock market did not go to zero
it went in half
and so
if you took out
if you had four hundred thousand dollars
at the beginning and you moved it to
money markets at the very bottom which
makes you the world's worst timing
then you've got 230 000 so that means
you lost half of your money
you can't say
we lost almost all no you did not not if
you were in a mutual fund it's actually
mathematically impossible that you would
have lost almost all of it there is not
a group of mutual funds that suck that
bad
that it went down 90 while the market
went down
50 it went from the dow went from 13 000
to 6 500.
i know i was there my investments did
the exact same thing i was here on the
radio sounding just exactly like your
cfo
don't jump off the train no one gets
hurt
except those that jump off in the middle
of a roller coaster ride the ride to the
end now if you had not dropped off
jumped off the train at the bottom you
would not have lost half of your money
because in just a few months the dow was
back to where it was pre
2008. oh by the way it was at 13 000.
then it went to 6500
you know it's over 30 000 today debbie
and so you would have had not 200 000
you would have had 1.2 million right now
if you had 230 000 at the bottom in 2008
and you had left it in there you'd have
1.2 million right now you didn't lose 59
000 debbie you lost a million dollars
ouch
you're being a debbie downer dave i want
you to know that i'm downing debbie
that's me
debbie we're just having some fun here
we're picking on you but
anyway that's the math i mean it's true
that's exactly people are scared to
invest i don't know um
with this man telling us it would go
back up and to stop watching it i don't
think he has any ulterior motives went
back up debbie um the cfo is not making
money from you being in a mutual fund or
in the 401k
cfos don't get commissions on 401ks
none whatsoever he's just trying to help
and the way that he's trying to give you
the essence and the nuances of the
market and so um and then the market's
back down it's tr it's trashed right now
it's it's horrible right this second
and um i mean
yeah yeah you you everybody's employed
and nobody's making money in the stock
market biden could screw up christmas
but
um the uh
yeah but but doesn't matter you know
what i'm doing this month i'm not taking
it out it's on sale debbie
ukraine
uh elon musk is buying the world
uh
what else is going wrong with the world
oh inflation oh that's right uh
gas housing market you name it president
cancering a sentence together uh
yeah i mean these are the things that
are happening out there and so the stock
market's going i'm so scared and it's
going down right so you know what i'm
doing
investing you know what i do when it
goes up i invest you know what i do when
it goes down i invest why because the
worst movement in the stock market's
history other than the great depression
was 2008 and debbie apparently if i'm
reading this right you managed to take
your money out at the exact worst time
i mean you you really hit it
amazingly bad
so you panicked at exactly the wrong
time you should have panicked earlier or
later or something but oh my gosh what's
the quote it's uh not about timing the
market it's time in the market it's
consistency yeah exactly just leave it
alone keep investing yeah you would you
lost out on 59 000 in 2021
but you've probably lost close to a
million dollars if you took this out at
the bottom
of the crash after 08 and moved it to
money markets and have made no money on
it since meanwhile my money's gone up 5
x
5x
since the bottom of the 2008 crash
really almost 6x technically um i mean
the dial is down a little bit right now
but it was up to 38 000 which would have
been 6x oh yeah so um
so that's why debbie that's why because
you're not really risking your
retirement fund if you quit taking it
out at the bottom you're risking not
being able to retire when you get 200
000 at retirement yeah
i mean let look at this okay here's
another thing this is for everybody
we're using debbie as an example bless
your heart but you walked into a debbie
so um
if the analysis i gave you is exactly
half wrong
in my case i'm i'm i'm half i'm off by
50
in the little math formula i just did on
the air okay which i'm not but let's
just say i'm off by that much
and you didn't have a million too
you're off by 50 you'd have 600 000.
it's still almost three times more than
you've got today
so this would have your cfo would have
had been
dramatically drastically wrong
like
wrong by thousands of percent
for you to end up with less than you do
now yeah
that's why he would be pushing for you
to risk your retirement fund uh you are
perceiving more risk with your emotions
than our is actually mathematically
there that's what we're saying that's
the summary and if i'm debbie i'm
sitting down with a smartvestor pro to
educate myself on what would have
happened if i left my money there
ride the ride educate myself on what i'm
actually investing in so i can make that
decision right now she needs that kind
of coach she's freaked out
yeah and you know george that um thing
we were talking about the other day um
there is a mutual fund
that opened in
in 1934
um it has averaged
since 1934 12.25
interest a rate of return
the number of years 87 years has been
open the number of times it's been down
16.
wow 16 years out of 87 it was down
the other year 71 years was up
so that's the type of thing that should
be in your in your mutual funds in your
401k
and that's even safer than the market
yeah you got to have a long-term mindset
this is the ramsey
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage tony
and brandy are with us hey guys how are
you hey you doing well good how are you
doing better than i deserve welcome so
good to have you guys thank you so how
much debt have you two paid off 34 000.
all right how long did this take about
five months good for you and your range
of income during that time 150. wow good
what do y'all do for a living i'm a ups
driver
and i'm a nurse i work in outpatient
surgery cool what kind of debt was your
34 000 my student loans
[Applause]
how long uh uh i'm sorry and let's see
here
so where do you guys live
we're from wilmington north carolina oh
yeah fun okay cool so what starts this
journey five months ago what happened
well it really started um like three
years ago my organization offered smart
dollar
and i was like i'm the free spirit so i
was like well i'll look at it i don't
know anything about financial stuff
anyways
and then i was like i'll tell tony about
it and i got into the first video where
it was saying like sell all your stuff
and gazelle intensity and i was like
that's not gonna work for me but i'll
tell tony anyways and we'll just see so
i was like have you ever heard about
this guy and he was like oh yeah i know
dave ramsey yeah yeah yeah and i was
like well i mean he has a lot of point
but um it sounds like it's more for like
the destitute which we are not
but we went ahead and listed all of our
debts out and we paid off a right good
bit so i think all together we've paid
about
71 000 off in the last three years but
then five months ago he
he's the one that really got intense
about it
yeah no i mean i just felt like we were
making that type of money and just kind
of never never getting ahead you'd have
money and then something would come up
and and it was gone um and
i think the biggest thing is we hadn't
combined our finances
and once we combined our finances it was
just a complete game changer um you know
we were on the same page and we started
started making moves together and
instead of
you know saving up four grand and then
spending three you know we just we just
went through this whole process and
you know 34 000 in five months it was
incredible boom just like that how long
you been married
nine years okay and in nine years you
just combined finances when you started
this journey five months ago yes wow we
had two separate checking accounts two
separate savings accounts and one joint
checking account that we put all of our
bills in and then based on our income
tony put in a bigger percentage than me
because he makes more than me
and then we all just kind of well i just
like spent all my money because i don't
ever save anything hardly until now and
he saved it all so if something came up
and he would have to pay for it he would
be resentful because he's like i've
saved up all this money and then i would
be like you also make more money so it
was always a fight back and forth and
since we combined everything we have an
account yeah and now we have an income
yeah and now we have savings and we do
spending yep yeah yeah okay so i i
certainly have a theory about this but
i'm curious why do you think the
combining accounts caused such an
increase in efficiency and lowered the
resentment you're set
well i mean i think that it just puts
you on the same page so instead of
working in different directions you're
working in one solid direction i think
just
everything just seems to to fit that way
when you're doing things separately
you're
you know i'm buying something she's
buying something and you you know you
never know what one side's doing and the
other side's doing so you're just never
on the same page that way
but also i mean
i think it just helps your marriage and
helps you become a stronger grouping
instead of just two individuals running
through life
so brandi you were would have been the
one most resistant to that because you
just kind of had you had it made i mean
you spent it your whole chat right so uh
i mean why give that up right i mean so
what would you say the benefits are now
that you guys combined them
from your perspective well i think it
was it was now both of ours both of our
money so i wasn't feeling like i was
getting like nickel i used to we used to
joke and i would say man you've been
nickel and diming me since we were
dating like we always split it it was 50
50 100 50 50 the whole time out of my
account and his account and um so then
it wasn't like we weren't like oh i paid
for this you know you owe me this it was
just like okay well we got to pay for
this and this is what we're doing and um
since i'm a nurse and i'm really loved
to chart so the every dollar app it was
like real fun to like chart everything
it was really um i didn't realize how
much money like
we actually had left over after we
budgeted
and you get to do spending because you
got to vote right yeah mm-hmm i mean
you're not like you like you're living
on beans and rice or something you
didn't have to do that no just knock
this out i mean you make a lot of money
so you just popped it in the head right
just reach over now i like that charting
thing with every dollar of course the
nurse would mention it's like charting i
like that i've never heard that analogy
but it's perfect yeah budgeting is like
charting yeah i like that i love this
story though because we get this all the
time people go well dave i'm not going
to combine finances guy got you know a
thousand reasons trust issues fear
selfishness financial infidelity but
when you guys combine this there was an
accountability there there was a
connection that could not be broken and
it obviously caused you guys to win
financially
yeah absolutely man yeah we actually had
planned for us to pay our that 34 000
off by this april but we paid it off in
november so now we're four five and six
so we already got our emergency fund and
now we're
home to four five and six now so we
finished it like seven months early and
look at the spender all up in the
knowledge
knows exactly where she is i love this
starting the budget and she's got her
spending under control
and shout out to your employer for for
having smart dollar as a benefit very
cool for those that don't know that is
our financial wellness program that we
offer to businesses organizations to
help their employees get control their
money so
yeah very cool the employee benefit
program uh that teaches our class is
what it amounts to and so very cool yeah
and
the husband or the spouse could actually
get involved and then it turns oh my
gosh then it goes wow we encourage that
yeah be careful be careful if you get
tony involved because it'll get
implemented
[Laughter]
well done you guys you're fun it's good
to talk to you
you got a real healthy uh outlook on
this whole thing you're comfortable in
your own skin to talk about it and that
that's uh um
you know that's a positive for everybody
listening and so it sounds like you're
doing fine you could just do better and
now you did better and now you're free
does it how does it feel to have zero
debt did you did you notice a change
yeah no it's like the the tension in
your shoulders just drops
you know you're like you don't know
anybody now it's time to go tackle the
house and and start moving in that
direction and
you know in our mid-40s we could we
could have no debt period house and
everything so and brandon you said that
was student loans from you
yes so how does that feel for that all
to be gone did you notice something when
it left or you're just kind of a course
of business okay check
well i mean i was happy i don't i'm not
i don't get like super really like
worked up about stuff i guess that's the
nurse in me too
yeah but i was like man we paid it off
that's great you know it was actually
from my undergrad my uh when i got my
bachelor's it i paid my job pay for it
and now i'm getting my doctorate and
we're actually cash flowing that too so
we're paying for my doctorate and paying
all this all of the debt off and doing
all the other stuff so
awesome good for you
good for you well done you guys you're a
power couple that's awesome stuff now
you bring the kiddo with you to do a
debt-free scream how old is he and
what's his name he's five this is reed
reed has reid been involved in all this
you know what's going on oh yes yeah he
listens to the ramsay show quite a lot
oh i'm sorry reed
we should get you some good music that's
a scar childhood right there
[Laughter]
well we got a copy of the baby steps
millionaires book for you that's
definitely the next chapter in your
story as well as a total money makeover
book for you to give away to someone and
stir up a holy ruckus with that thing
somewhere tell them what you did i'm
proud of you guys well done
very well done you're a great couple
tony and brandi and reed from north
carolina 34 000 paid off due mainly to
uh combining their accounts and their
goals and their values did it in five
months making 150 count it down let's
hear a debt free scream
three two one
[Music]
he understood the assignment way to go
buddy
that's awesome oh man
it's amazing how people can share a bed
share dna share a child but they won't
share a bank account dave that's just
too personal
wow
i love a story like that
oh
man that's awesome way to go smart
dollar team good work yes this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day first
thessalonians 5 16-18 rejoice always
pray continually give thanks in all
circumstances for this is god's will for
you
in christ jesus gk chesterson said i
would maintain that thanks are the
highest form of thought and that
gratitude is happiness
doubled by wonder
oh that's good i like that
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today ashley is with us in
dallas hi ashley how are you
hi i'm okay how are you
better than i deserve what's up kiddo
good thank you um i am calling i'm going
to try to keep this as clear as i can
i'm in a bit of a complicated situation
um but i just found out that
about three weeks ago
that i am
expecting a child yay
this would be my first
thank you
um
however it
is
um
i
the person that you know would be the
father would be my ex-husband
um
and um i'm not
sure at this moment if he will be
around
um it's you know he's being very
unclear about that
um apparently he was around recently
yeah
yeah definitely
yeah
yeah it's crazy
but i mean he says that he
i mean i'm not getting that he's opposed
to it he says he's okay with it at the
same time he's not really talking to me
um how old are you i'm just confused
um i am 34. he is 42. uh-huh do you have
a job um
does he have a job yes do you have other
children from the marriage
no no okay
so how long have you been divorced
um
about three and a half years okay
yeah how much do you how much do you
make of your honey
me um well i have a disability so i'm
doing like maybe 17 000
before taxes a year because i can't
really work too much what is the nature
of your disability
um so i have multiple sclerosis so i
have some mobility issues
and
vision a little bit
i'm just kind of a myriad of things
you got family you got family in the
area
um i have um my adopted mom she's kind
of close ish
she's about an hour away from me
um
so that's all i really have
um in that regard
but i'm just kind of lost because i
don't know
how to prepare for this financially
i'm i understand i'm going to probably
need to change some things living
situation wise because i live in a very
small apartment that's only 324 square
feet i have a very small car it's like a
small like a smart car
um
and i just got told it probably will
need a new engine so
i'm gonna have to replace that and i
just don't know how i'm going to do all
of this financial lives especially with
the rent being like it is and the car
prices being the way that they are
um i just don't know how i'm going to do
this and prepare for this child
financially especially if i may have to
do it alone
so and i don't really know exactly yet
but um
um
there's so much going on here i'm so
sorry
that's a scary scary situation you find
yourself in
okay so yeah what i would
tell my best friend if they called and
told me the exact thing you told me
is i would tell them that you need to
get people in your corner as much as
possible that's why i was asking about
friend
our family i i would um
definitely start working on the career
side of your equation find something
that you're able to do that makes a lot
more money that is within the tolerance
of your ms
is as i understand is aggravated by
stress so you can't be in a high stress
scenario but you're getting ready to be
and i stress you're getting ready to be
in a stressful financial situation if
you don't create some more income so you
have to create some more income
i would uh uh
do do you belong to or have you visited
or are you aware of a local church in
your area that you respect
um
well i've been going to a church online
um which one it's not really in my area
oh okay um
yeah it's in oklahoma um but i know of
one
that's in the area that i can
you know get connected with i want you
to get connected so you've got emotional
support
and when they know what you're going
through maybe even some financial
support temporarily while you get your
income up and you make a transition to
different living and different vehicle
but don't do any of it with debt because
that's going to bring you down further
we got to get your income up and make
these moves
right yeah yeah but you've got you're
going to have to have some people around
you
that are walking with you and are
supporting you
um emotionally financially relationally
everything because you're
you're kind of by yourself out here on a
limb and you're scared
right yeah yeah that's exactly what i
feel right now i'm like i feel like i
was
you know i'm
almost basically out of debt i only have
like 150 left on a medical loan my
student loan was discharged so that's
another thing that is kind of hindering
me on the income side but that's good
well i can still be discharged you've
been permanently you've been declared
permanently disabled the student loan is
gone it doesn't come back
if you go get a job it doesn't come back
and so you you've got the rest of your
life to live and create an income and 17
000 isn't a good life
so we need to work on this income side
of the equation long term for you and
for the baby
um lastly while you're at that church
ask um the folks there if there is an
attorney there that could give you some
advice i'm not an expert on the law in
texas but in most states
your
ex-husband is going to be responsible
for child support
whether he wants to be involved or not
legally
in most states a percentage of his
income will go to raise the child
that he caused to come into the world
and i don't really care whether he likes
it or not i'm not really taking a poll
here of his feelings
i'm worried about one thing and that's
the child
yeah no thank you i appreciate that
because i was like i don't know what my
my rights are since you know this is
new you know and i'm not sure what your
rights are either but i suspect your due
child support that's my suspicion
yeah and so i would you know and i think
you're probably gonna have to get uh
someone to help you at least coach you a
little bit on the legal side so you can
have this discussion with him and he can
do this voluntarily or will have a judge
instruct him to do it whichever he
prefers
yeah yeah i hope that we can work that
out but no thank you yeah and i i think
so here's the here's what i think i'm
saying
i think if you have some family support
some community and church support and
some money coming from the father
and you start to adjust your income in
your living situation in your car
situation by the time you make all those
adjustments this is all going to be okay
but you're going to need all of those
things bringing to bear on the problem
yeah
i'm so sorry you're going through this
ashley let us know if we can help down
the line as you sort through this and
figure out what the next steps are but
uh that's a real tough thing to be
walking through and you've got to have
those people in your corner so i love
the idea of you plugging into a local
church
yeah so hang on kelly i'll pick up and
we're going to get you signed up for
financial peace university online so you
can go through the class
and get in the every dollar app that'll
help you manage the money as you
increase your income from child support
and from a changed career you'll be able
to manage that because your income is
getting ready to double or triple by the
time we finish with all these things
here
um should anyway
and so we got to get you to 34 maybe to
45 thousand but time all the smoke
clears on this
and um you know you've also gotta
investigate uh you know what your
uh medical insurance situation is uh for
the labor and delivery and start
preparing for that as well but we'll
walk with you we're here in your corner
if you get scared and you need some more
help you call us anytime hon
wow
it's heartbreaking george good
good show today good show george and
james and ben and kelly in the booth
kelly celebrating 10 years with ramsay
today
and uh i saw her tenure ramsay versary
yeah good stuff that puts this hour of
the ramsey show in the books we'll be
back with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the prince of
peace
christ jesus
[Music]
do you love a good dave rand want wanna
see the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
you